Mài tìm nở năm trong xây rì
Thế, tại nhẹ mới từ huy đại
Chứ tất cả xả mặt nạm
Giac Nam
Bộ bá tại nhẹ mài tìm nở năm trong xây rì gồm
Nở năm trong mà
Nở năm trong lợi á
Và nở năm trong năm buổi lợi á
Vừa được huy đại thành công thương mại giá mắt tại giac Nam
Tại trong thương mục tiến
Thế xa thị bẩy tấn
Thùng cao một cái chi mẹ
Giải đến bốn tảy nạm mẹ
Chờ được yêu hàng
Nhưng nhẹ dí chuyển cho phương dở hạn chế
Và phương dàng chế hẹn
Đóng cơ để bốn xây bề mạnh mẽ
Lốt bẩy chấm thông thông ra mời sấu chữ cải tốt
Bên bị trên mọi cú đợt
Dấm cao khoảng
Cung gầm chắc chắn
Dút bởi vì hình dế dàng
Dứ hạn hoả luôn án toàn
Nở năm trong xây rì
Vũ chậc đà dạc lại thùng
Bù vạc, kín, lượng
Còn bù dích, hay đông lạnh
Cù hợp yếu năm sản
Thế phẩm đến hạn yêu dụng dành
Đặc biệt
Từ nay đến, mọi lòng tháng 12 năm
Hình cú chong hai lắm
Mũ sẽ nợ năm sản bản rao thành công
Hát tệ xe bề và đại lý xích
Chích bà chữ đồng, tự xanh thù
Bảo quyền mình đại ương mầm sản
Cũng chậc của ném thông thông thông tài
Hố khăn trên bằng quốc
Thì hìp càm kết của hát tệ xe bì trong việc đồng hạn
Cung gốc đồng
Vá thế chẻ tại Việt Nam